peace be with you welcome to the DS show
we have an exciting show for you today
now there are many beautiful things that
we get to enjoy from the creation of the
Creator and one of those blessings that
we have a responsibility with is the
body that the Creator has given us what
are we putting in it how many of us now
be City is on the rise heart disease all
these ailments and many of us are
suffering from these what does Islam
have to say about it do we have the
solutions there or we're gonna be
talking to our next guest dr. Saeed
doctor of Oriental Medicine here in the
Dean show to give us some of the Islamic
solutions when we come back don't go
anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
peace be with you Salaam alaikum
when I come how are you Hawaii dockside
awesome
I'm the LA tell us to see you nice to
see you to tell us a little bit about
yourself and when we talk about doctor
of Oriental Medicine because people look
at you to say he's not Chinese what do
ya know yeah I know I studied formally
in the u.s. what's called oriental
medicine so within that scope of
practice we study acupuncture Chinese
herbal medicine dietary therapy
cupping and more obviously we get a
background in Western medicine and its
techniques as well but it's kind of a
coverage of different natural techniques
yeah so so for you know a lot of the MDS
as a medical doctors say look why you
need that I'll just write them a
prescription I'll put my antibiotics
what's going on that's right
yeah and you absolutely could but it's
just different philosophies regarding it
our philosophy is that you go with
what's safest and most natural first
we're not totally putting down drugs and
pharmaceuticals but what we're saying is
that if you have certain health issues
it behooves you to follow what's safest
first and order and proceed in order of
caution yeah yeah because the fact is
drugs do have a lot of side effects that
accumulate over time toxicities that
accumulate over time so go with what's
safe and natural first and if you still
need it then by all means that makes
sense because many people now they don't
read the warning labels I mean like 30
40 50 side-effects so you may be cure
this one possibly temporarily the next
thing you know you got a lump growing on
the back of your head we all have heard
the commercials where you know they'll
sneak in like 40 side effects that
they're he'd like in ten seconds and
they'll say including death and fainting
and so we all have heard those ads but
yeah it's it's it's really all about
going with what's safest and
proceeding in order of caution and even
when we look at our faith Islam you know
you look at the time of the Prophet SAW
solemn and the foods they used to eat
the natural medicines they used to use
it's a totally different air than and
now but the fact is that Islam advocates
using the means that Allah has sent down
to us meaning through the natural foods
and plans the herbs all the techniques
that have been provided us to the to us
by the Prophet SAW Solomon using those
I'm a firm believer in this the natural
way that Allah the Creator has provided
these remedies these healing remedies in
these plants and lot of this these
natural things are out there tell us
another way that has been a tradition
that somewhat been lost I think it's
being revived now the heat JAMA talked
about this the the Sunnah the way of the
promise of some and the he Channel yeah
subhanAllah it's really an amazing thing
and and that's why I was actually
visiting Chicago this weekend to do a
workshop on the medicine of the prophets
what a lot of solo as well as about hey
JAMA we offered that service at my
clinic in Dallas we do offer that
service of Hatami it's something
extraordinary just to give you an
example I mean there are over 15 20 a
hadith from the Prophet SAW so I'm
confirming how important it is but one
of the strongest ones that's mentioned
in soon and eben magis says that when
the prophet sallallaahu Solon went on
the Asura and Miraj the night ascension
to Jerusalem and then up into the
heavens there's a narration that says
that he didn't pass by a single angel
without each and every one of them
telling him to prescribe pohjanmaa to
your own a lot if you imagine it is
really deep and when I saw I was amazed
by that and it's an authentic hadith but
imagine the Angels telling you to go
back and do hey JAMA you know that gives
you a small taste of it in Bihari -
there's a hadith that says hi Roma tada
wait on the hill Hazama that amongst the
best of remedies is Hazama and so it
does have a great tradition going back
from that time till now
and you know people were using it even
before the prophet saw some too so it
shows actually some level of tolerance
to and it's long a lot of people don't
realize this where the ancient Greeks
were performing a type of cupping or
bloodletting the Chinese were doing it
in the Indian subcontinent they were
using leeches for a similar purpose but
the Prophet SAW said I'm like most thing
he had adopted what he felt was good and
then he put his stamp on it you know in
terms of when to do it the odds that you
recite the points that are used the
purposes and so forth so he put his mark
on it now what is it most people if you
asked you even to Muslims
hey JAMA you mentioned John I have no
idea what this is now what is he JAMA
explain to us and the benefits of it
sure it's basically a technique for
detoxifying the blood it involves making
very tiny incisions on the skin and
using suction to draw out what we call
capillary or surface blood that is
thought to have certain toxins number
one there in several Muslim countries
doctors have analyzed the blood that
comes out in Hajj Amin they found very
interesting things but not only does
this blood contain higher amount of
certain toxins contains a higher amount
of certain inflammatory compounds that
they've measured it contains a higher
percentage of what we call old dead red
blood cells that haven't been excreted
and metabolized there were differences
in white blood cell content differences
in iron the bottom line was for health
purposes it's good to extract that blood
periodically and it's one of the best
preventive things you can do but it's
also a treatment tool diabetes you're
suffering from fatigue and a lot of the
other ailments now eating bad foods can
we talk about this when we come back on
the Deen show with dr. Syed don't go
anywhere
please subscribe to the DCO follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Deen show heart disease on
the rise diabetes
so what what a lot of depression and
linked back to food fatigue what do you
thought so yeah I mean probably one of
the most neglected aspects and most
fundamental aspects of our health and
our our control over it is definitely
diet and diet plays a huge role with
respect to all these and this is not
just me saying it or natural passing it
the America the medical community is
also recognizing that it's it's not just
about diet but you know it's a big part
of it exercise as part of it stress
management is part of it but the fact is
the standard American diet is what
spells sad right and it is sad because
the fact is and a lot of us as Muslims
have unfortunately gotten co-opted into
this we come here and were hit with such
abundant sources of food that we don't
pay attention to the quality of the food
the fact is in the Quran it says Kulu
min Tabata motto suck nakum and it says
this repeatedly that you eat amongst eat
those things which are play about but
you bad some people translate is that
which is whole or wholesome and pure so
when we really think about our week you
know things we eat like donuts gummy
bears
you know Twinkies potato chips or is
that tell you about you know I was
listening to a scholar once he was
saying you could make an easy argan that
it's not we've got it as you said
earlier we've got to go back to things
that Allah has made you know he's sent
as down so many blessings in there and
we've got to go back to those sources
but even with that as you know human
beings have complicated things with our
animals were feeding them growth hormone
antibiotics or giving a protein feeds
for animals that are herbivores you know
with grains we've got genetic
engineering going on with soy with soy
with wheat with corn when it comes to
other processed foods you've got food
additives preservatives colorings you
name it right flavor enhancers it's
overwhelming when you start to analyze
it but the fact is we've got to go back
to the basics eating fruits vegetables
whole grains moderate amounts of protein
you know and going back to the basics
because that's where the root of
diseases and the profits are some also
said that the root of diseases is where
in the stomach or in in digestion so
we've got out we've got more time
looking at the hem we're going to have a
article posted up by a a person who had
actually taught his family now after he
did research and they were going through
you know many things that the home is
going through where and not only the
tooth decay from sugar but also the the
scientists doctors talking about this
heart disease so what he replaced the
word sugar with poisel is an absolutely
that's well documented and their whole
documentaries on this hold books written
on this subject
and speaking of relevancy just some of
you our viewers may have seen in
national headlines just within the last
two weeks where the medical associations
revised their guidelines on cholesterol
did you see any of that yeah they came
back in a you know four years
unfortunately doctors were scaring
people from eating eggs and nuts and
shellfish and things like that it's
actually good for you and they finally
admitted that after years which we've
been saying for years but in the same
guidelines they admitted the much bigger
problem is what sugar and too much
simple carbohydrates so what happens is
when you over consume the breads the
pasta is the chips the rice the sweets
the desserts that starts getting
converted to triglycerides and
cholesterol and and increasing what we
call systemic inflammation so sugar by
definition increases inflammation that's
not only a risk for heart or risk for
heart disease and diabetes but affects a
lot of other things too like you said
dental issues and much more so it's a
very serious problem and like I said
earlier the biggest difference between
human beings of the past or even if you
just go back a few decades the level of
sugar consumption has skyrocketed is out
of control and and you know that sugar
is not an essential nutrient there's no
such thing as sugar deficiency or
coca-cola deficiency all right we need
whole live nutrients we need live
vitamin
minerals enzymes antioxidants from
natural foods and like I said
unfortunately among Muslims too we have
this notion that we can just eat what
Sabiha and as long as we're having halal
and Sabiha everything is fair game right
but we've got to take a more nuanced
look at this and really analyze what
we're eating and as you said health is
one of the biggest blessings that have
been given to us in opium says that
after Iman health is the second biggest
blessing given to us so we do our best
to protect it we're going to come back
and give some solutions some things that
people can take out of the diet put in
the diet to more specifics that they can
start right now and today to clean up
that fridge and right back to give you
these here on the Dean show ladies and
gentlemen this is your captain speaking
welcome aboard flight five two three
five non-stop to London Heathrow the
temperature is 25 degrees outside and we
are expecting a fairly smooth flight
today in a few moments the flight
attendants will be passing around the
cabin to offer you hot and cold drinks
we thank you for choosing to fly with us
today and we hope you enjoy your flight
thank God it was just a dream good I
don't believe in God ladies and
gentlemen the captain has turned on the
fasten seatbelt sign
you
[Music]
[Music]
please subscribe to the Bijou follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Dean show ok so there was a
documentary called fed up have you did
you see it I never heard that one but
I've heard of it yes you know they've
showed like the not only poison of sugar
being poisoned actually for the body but
now how it's so addictive just like
cocaine like these drugs the brain
lights up you know about this that's
right the studies are you're absolutely
right they're showing that it is as
addictive as certain drugs including
cocaine and that's why we've got to
treat it accordingly you know there was
a naturopathic doctor who was listening
to several weeks ago and he was saying
that if you have a somebody who's like
an alcoholic or a drug addict and he
goes in and checks in at a one of those
rehab centers you don't give them a
little bit of alcohol each day and say
here we're gonna slowly wean you down
and but you can have a little bit each
day right so this dot the point of this
doctor and there's also another book by
the way from a medical doctor called the
ten day detox the sugar solution it's
another good book on the subject he
gives a very practical program on how
people can help quit this addiction and
he says you have to treat it as that
because a lot of people think that while
I can still have my cookies after every
meal and I'll just try to uh slowly cut
it down but it doesn't happen usually
yeah it takes a lot more strictness
where sometimes you've got to cut it cut
the cord and make some hard decisions
and start replacing it with real food
and you know earlier we were talking
about replacing some of these sugars and
some of these simple carbs with with
more vegetables with more wholesome
proteins anything cream or fiber with
greens but you know Allah has made so
much and we try to get organic pure
sources of these vegetables fruits
proteins whole grains fibers and start
replacing those but it can be done you
know where there's a will there's a way
but we've got to treat it as an
addiction yeah I see
some really good documentaries have you
seen fat sick and almost dead
juicing saved my life what do you think
about it absolutely that's one of my
favorite documentaries I have most of my
patients who come to us in Dallas watch
that I myself my wife and we have many
patients go through this where we get
them on that that juicing habit because
you know some people will eat some
vegetables but all most studies show and
including from the FDA that the most
common deficiency of most people not
only in this country but in other
countries is in the vegetable fruit area
we're not getting enough live enzymes
vitamins and minerals and so we've got
to put more focus on that besides eating
things like salads the other way to do
that is through blending or juicing I
myself use more of the blenders where I
put in you know certain vegetables and
fruits blend it all up add some water
because it retains the fiber you know
Allah put that fiber in there for a
reason and you drink it and it doesn't
taste bad you can play around Allah has
made thousands of thousands no
vegetables and fruits so there's a lot
to choose from but yeah you can make
combinations and you consume that on a
daily basis and that's probably one of
the best things you can do for your
health yeah we just recently I can tell
you we had a patient come to us an
American and he was probably 260 to 270
pounds he was snoring he's a borderline
diabetic he had gout he had severe
allergies his wife would just leave the
room because he was snoring like a you
know a truck you know the poor guy came
in and that's situation he got started
on the juicing and blending and much
like the documentary you mentioned
hummed a lot he lost more than 50 pounds
within like eight weeks his snoring went
down his allergies went down his blood
sugar started a normalized his BP
started don't normalize that gout got
better and that's all from what zero
medication just diet change a change in
diet yeah and he was just consuming
vegetables and fruits all day that's all
he would do so now if you eliminate you
go on your fridge right
most people it's sad to say you look you
maybe you got this Hawaiian Punch
you've got the RC Pepsi any kind of
sodas right you got fruitcake I mean
these these chocolate cakes and white
bread and whatever it is you know it's
similar to this this has got to go yeah
and then like I said it's not easy
because as you said earlier the society
pushes it on every level you walk into
the store there's candy everywhere
you're standing in the aisle it's candy
everywhere sweets
everywhere and and they know that they
prey on your weakness right yeah as of
that addiction but again knowledge is
key when you're aware of its risks when
you're aware that it is a type of poison
that increases inflammation in your body
increases the risk for disease that can
at least be the first step in making a
change but our I would urge all our
viewers to really start researching this
and getting more information and you'll
see that that's one of the easiest and
best steps you can take for you and your
family is to start at the very least
cutting it down I know it's very hard to
realistically cut out all sugars hundred
percent but start you know as the
profits or some settings and slow
gradations and make make the change but
that's one of the best things you can do
how about substituting let's say the
dates as you know for some replace of
these process jumps right yeah and
fruits have sweetness obviously there's
fruit yeah honey dates yeah honey date
yes that's right so and what one key
thing to point out on that for viewers
because a lot of times we get that
question and they say well can I just
replace all my sugar with honey or dates
but isn't that sugar too and isn't that
still bad so the key difference I could
point out is that the difference between
dates and like a honey button is that
dates have other nutrients in it they
have other vitamins other minerals
antioxidants in it that change or
moderate the body's response to it so
for example you may have heard of
insulin right the insulin response
changes when something has fiber in it
versus a honey bun that's going to give
you a whack you get an insulin spike
which is associated not only with
diabetes but all type
other negative effects on the body so
yes you you shouldn't overdo obviously
shouldn't be you know gulping down honey
and like a pound a day or eating 50
dates a day but with in moderation you
know you get that sweet craving you have
some of that you know that's good but
they're not processed or handled by the
body in the same way but yeah we
shouldn't overdo anything and you will
have definitely by cleaning up your diet
more clarity of mind
fatigue energy levels will go up a lot
of these ailments that we talked about
and they'll start to be eradicated from
your life and this is proven in some of
those documentaries like the fat sick
and almost dead that you recommend I
really recommend that people watch more
water
that's right absolutely and and the
source of water is important too I still
know a lot of Muslims who unfortunately
just drink in their tap water if you
look at the studies on tap water is
still full of certain contaminants that
the government or local government still
allows yeah certain heavy metals but the
fact is you need to get as purified and
as clean of water as possible have you
heard of berkey water filters not Burke
you have heard Berkeley or something
like this where they have four filters
and it's you can actually put like rain
water in there it filters out it's like
a double filtrate yes yes yes yes no no
it's not reverse doesn't take the
minerals but what which one do you
recommend what do you recommend that's
out there that people can ask because
that's again the source what you're
talking about that's very important yeah
at the least it needs you know what we
call a double filtration some units will
add the reverse osmosis step you don't
have to have it but if you can it's
better I myself in my own home have put
on one of those units that filters the
supply supply lines yes looking just
about getting it from the fridge you
know it's about filtering the whole
supply if you can yeah so that's there
are a lot of units that sell in the
market yeah I don't want to advocate for
a particular brand but so there are a
lot out there so so I mean this is a
huge vast topic we've given people some
things that can do immediately but
definitely getting educated on this is
crucial to living a good healthy life
absolutely yeah really beautiful thank
you so much for being with us thank you
again also the author of the god Islam
in a skeptic mind yes where can people
contact you and also get the book yeah
this book is available at amazon.com and
you can contact us through there if you
contact the seller we also get messages
through that or through Amazon so we'd
be more than happy to help you with that
thank you very much thank you something
I like them
and there you have it on the Dean show
some practical tips some advice some
things that you can take out put in
they'll help you live a more vibrant
energetic life and we know from the last
and final messenger said the man kind of
problem home peace be upon him who was a
brother Jesus Moses Abraham they all
submitted to the crater not the creation
they brought the truth based on proof
and he said the son of Adam doesn't feel
anything worse than the belly yes
diseases come from here when we don't
put in the good stuff and what we put in
the bad junk and then he said enough is
some few snacks morsels of food to keep
his back upright but if he's overtaken
one third third food one third air and
one third water and should be sufficient
along with now putting in the right not
the sugars and all the processed foods
that have been altered and changed by
the hands of man they're natural organic
good foods vegetables fruits those
things that will help you to again live
a healthy life watch those documentaries
that we recommended start today
subscribe we'll see you next time here
to dean show until then peace be with
you please subscribe to the DCO follow
us on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the be show by
making a donation in the link below